[Music]
elon musk is the billionaire ceo of
spacex and tesla and was ranked by
forbes as number 21
on their list of the world's most
powerful people he went from being
raised by his abusive father in the
suburbs of south africa to now being one
of the richest people in the world with
a net worth of
27.9 billion dollars and today we're
gonna learn his best advice on how you
should start
thinking
rise and shine it's espresso
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and every
morning i bring you a shot of espresso
to help you believe in yourself more and
start your day with confidence
so good morning i believe in you and
let's do this
over to you elon musk i think it's also
important to
reason from first principles rather than
by analogy
so the normal way that we conduct our
lives is we we we reason by analogy
it's we're doing this because it's like
something else that was done
or it's like what um other people are
doing me too
type ideas yeah it's like yeah slight
iterations yeah
on on a theme um and and uh
and it's it because it's it's kind of
mentally easier to reason
by analogy rather than from first
principles but by first principles is
kind of a physics way of
looking at the world and what that
really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what are we sure is
true or
sure is possible is true and then reason
up from there that takes a lot more
mental energy
um give me an example of that like
what's one thing that you've you've done
that on that you feels worked for you
sure so um somebody could say um
in fact people do uh that battery packs
are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the past
um you're like well no that's that's
pretty dumb
you know because if if if you apply that
reasoning to
anything new that then
you wouldn't be able to ever get to that
new thing
your dream is possible the business you
want to build
the life that you want to lead the
impact that you want to make
it's possible it really is even if
nobody
like you has done it before there are a
million reasons why
your idea will not work and eat why it
will
which side you choose to focus on will
determine your life
so i'm an introvert that may be hard to
to realize or hard to tell because when
i get on camera when i'm talking
entrepreneurs i get excited i get
animated
but i'm an introvert at heart i don't
talk to people on the airplane i hate
networking events
being in big groups causes me anxiety
i'm
super awkward and you know don't know
what to say whenever i'm
kind of put into a group i'm not the
life of a party i'd rather be by myself
and so i'm very introverted and i used
to believe
that that would be a big roadblock for
me if you look back on
on the history of my helping
entrepreneurs as
my website and then my youtube channel i
always hid behind
the the famous people i always hid
behind sharing my story because
i didn't think it was relevant or as
important or powerful
like hey you got this chance to learn
from elon musk who cares about evan
carmichael
and for the longest time on my channel
evan carmichael's top 10 rule of success
was the number one request
and it always blew my mind like why who
cares
right i mean all these great stories why
does it matter about me
and i was always reluctant to share my
story and i always felt like
because i'm an introvert i don't know
how this is going to work out
when i when i look to people who've done
it when i look to
other people built big youtube channels
or great communicators or fantastic on
stage
they look like they have it all figured
out i love young les brown he's my
greatest
motivational speaker of all time when i
look at someone like les brown
it's hard to imagine him being an
introvert he seems to be
always happy the life of a party has got
stories to share
and if i if i want to be like that i
want to be a speaker
i always told myself i can't because i'm
introverted
and he's not and so i don't know how to
bridge the gap
and so that's where you know people like
me haven't won before
people like me haven't done it before at
least the ones that i knew of
and so it's easy to say well because it
hasn't done before now
now you can't do it as well what i
discovered was you know what i still
care about serving
i still care about helping i still want
to make a big impact
i want to i want to be able to touch
people's lives even if i don't
want to small talk and chat with them
and be the life of a party and that is
possible
and once i shifted it to service once i
shifted it to recognizing that
i'm not even here for me i'm not on
stage for me i'm not in this room
for me i'm in this room to serve and
using your perceived weakness as a
strength thinking things like
i'm an introvert so i don't talk much
but i'm a great listener
i'm a fantastic listener i can very
quickly understand
what you're going through and how you're
feeling and now i can use that to
make better content and to help shift
you and move you to where you need to
get
and those things of understanding that
that i am service built and so are you
and that just because other people
haven't done it doesn't mean that i
can't
really help give me the confidence
belief motivation
momentum to keep going there are always
going to be reasons
why you can't win there's going to be a
million reasons right a million reasons
why you can't win
and eight why you will five eight ten
but a smaller amount of reasons why you
will and if you start talking to your
friends and talk to your family and
and compare yourself to other people
you're gonna find the same thing of now
there's three million reasons why you
can't win
and it's really just that choice to
figure out which are you gonna focus on
the three million reasons why you can't
win or the eight why you can
now i've got a three-step process i'm
going to walk you through that i think
will really help
but before that if you want to have
unstoppable confidence and learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
they're free the links are joined in the
description below there are just times
when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear if you
have a great product lots of people will
buy it
and then the company will be successful
that that ended up being worse than if
we had designed a car from
from the beginning okay so how do we do
it how do we overcome our limitations
our lack of belief
and start making momentum three steps
let's go
step number one is get clear on your
goals you know what what do you want
what's the problem that you're trying to
solve right if you don't have that
direction
it's gonna be really really hard for you
actually to build it so i want to solve
the world's biggest problem i think
people
don't believe in themselves enough i
think everybody has michael jordan
elon musk level talent and something and
chances are it's not what your parents
did it's not what your family did it's
not what you went to school for
something
totally different and step one is
actually believing that that is possible
and so i'm trying to unlock
as many people as possible on my journey
fully recognizing that it's never going
to happen
but trying to unlock as many people
along along my path while i'm still here
on this earth and so having that clear
goal having that clear mission for what
i want to try to accomplish
makes everything else easier so for you
what do you want to accomplish
what's your goal who are you trying to
serve what are you trying to do and try
to get as clear and specific as possible
because having that definiteness of
purpose
gives you the boldness gives you the
confidence gives you
the ability to stand on that rock when
there's
waves are coming at you when you're in
quicksand all around you
and and people throwing a lot of hate at
you if you don't have that rock to stand
on
you're gonna get caught up in the storm
your goals your purpose your mission
that's the rock that you need to stand
on step number two is find your eight
ways
so like i said before there's a million
reasons why it's not gonna work and
eight while it will
you don't need eight eight is an
abundance of reasons you only need one
of those eight to work
out and so you'll have all those doubts
and all those people in your ear telling
you why i can't work out
stop focusing on why it won't work stop
focusing on what you don't have
stop focusing on why you're not good
enough that's not gonna serve you this
is gonna keep you
in in molasses land it's gonna keep you
in preventing
you from actually moving forward and now
live in a life that you hate right keeps
you stuck
you have to focus on the eight reasons
why you can't so
for a moment you know close your eyes
and imagine that was possible
and there are even though yes there are
many reasons why i won't there are eight
reasons why
find the eight and spend all your time
all your energy all your effort all your
love
on those eight reasons why it can work
out
even though there's all these reasons
why it won't and then step number three
is build immediate momentum
once you've got your eight what are you
gonna do about it
just finding the eight and writing it
down on a piece of paper or putting down
the comments below that's not gonna
help anything yet the the ideation is
fantastic but nothing happens until you
do something
the biggest thing missing for most
people for most entrepreneurs is just
momentum
you've got great ideas you're genius the
stuff in here could change the world
but it's not going to change the world
if it stays stuck in here you've got to
birth it it has to happen you need
momentum
and stop making it so big and impossible
and overwhelming that now you need
millions of dollars in a team and all
this stuff that you don't have
bring it down that that is motivating
that's inspiring that's amazing
right that big mission but bring it down
to what are you gonna do right now
what can you do today to actually start
building momentum
don't worry about the perfect plan and
just create immediate momentum on the
eight reasons why
you can win now i've got a really
special bonus script that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
is your single biggest takeaway from
this video and what are you going to do
this week to take action on it put it
down in the comments below
when you schedule in what day what time
what place you're going to take action
on your idea
you are 91 likely going to actually
follow through
versus just 35 likely to follow through
when you got motivated but had no plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability
you raise your chances of following
through even more
so right now in the comments below share
your single biggest takeaway and your
plan of action for the following week
put it down below
so i can celebrate with you this world
today is full of challenges and
opportunities
2 000 years ago full of challenges
and opportunities and i'm sure 2000
years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there's always
it depends on how you look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people
say there's no opportunity i complained
a lot when i was young because i think
bill gates took all the opportunities
for the microsoft
and steve jobs all these guys there's no
job
there's no great big stuff
left for us but i think
[Music]
opportunity always lies in the
challenges
always lies in the complaints if you can
solve the challenge
you have you will be successful the big
challenge you solve
the big problem or the the big
opportunity you have
if you want more inspiration morning
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there